[Music]
john said i'm leaving to be with yoko
and paul said is this some kind of joko
yes paul mccartney settles the score on
who broke up the fab four in a bbc
interview that will be broadcast next
month that we won't be listening to paul
mccartney pushes back on the narrative
that he was the reason that the beatles
broke up more than 50 years ago that's a
long time i'm saying the real reason was
that john was making a new life with
yoko added paul john walked into a room
one day and said i'm leaving the beatles
is that instigating the split or not
well maybe that's how they wrote hello
goodbye
mccartney insisted that he has no hard
feelings against yoko and that she and
john were a great couple but he does
hope to outlive ringo
that's a lie but let's not forget that
following lenin's departure the music
took a noticeable turn
yesterday
oh my troubles seem so hard
[Music]
all right
my theory tyrus is like okay i believe
that lennon was right to get out then
because if the beatles had stuck around
as a group they would have put out
lesser and lesser quality products and
they'd be rich but they'd be like you
too like you two should have stopped
after unforgettable fire or maybe what's
the album with the floor joshua tree
joshua what's the okay maybe they did a
lot of good albums
theory is wrong arrow
aerosmith after toys in the attic i
don't know
i'm sorry man but yes did anyone wake up
this morning going we've got to find out
no no no no kids we're not going to
school today daddy's got to know
was it ringo was it yo-yo
was it john
was it the man
and we already know it's ringo yes
ringo did it yes he was the one going
back and forth telling each guy he was
better than he really was and he was
like man if paul if you were in charge
man i'd get more drum solos and then he
would go to john and be like hey paul
said i could get more drum solos if you
sang less so we know who did it we know
who did it it was ringo's punk ass who
did it he he broke the team up
that's it you know what i did that's the
first time i've ever heard anybody blame
ringo
he was in a great movie called caveman i
don't know if anybody saw that i had a
bird named ringo i was a huge beatles
fan growing up and i don't really know
why and then ringo ruined it
and then but i had a bird named ringo
that my mom made me give give away
somebody got a job bingo let you down
he's been doing it
but you shouldn't apologize for being a
beatles fan is one of the greatest no i
know but it's so funny because my
parents never listened to the beatles
that much and i just found them and they
are one of the greatest musical acts of
all times obviously and so i love them
but um i saw somebody this is not my
idea i saw somebody post online earlier
yoko ono was to the beatles what meghan
markle is to the royal family
that's not mine and i'm not saying that
i'm just throwing it out there but
you're just asking questions that
implies that
prince harry has talent
[Applause]
know what's funny
but you know what's funny to me is that
when i was growing up the beatles were
the good band and the rolling stones was
the scary band and that surely the
rolling stones would be the one that
would disintegrate you know because they
were the bad boys and here you are it's
like 60 years the stones have been
around right clearly the beatles had
great hairstyles so we could start with
that and beyond that i would say are you
saying that because your hair looks like
i mean this guy looks like he's you know
well mccartney on the far right there i
think he's got a good quaff but i will
say this am i the only person up here
thinks the beatles are a little
overrated let's just take this for a
second let's just take this for a second
no but thank you you guys are usually
exhausted
so many people have said that oh the
beetles aren't even good you're like i'm
gonna come on the show and be a badass
so cool i'm too cool for the beatles
let's see what you've got
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i just said they're a little overrated
i'd love to hear an album from you yeah
you and clay travis work on it
eels aren't even good it's the beatles
i'll have you know and i get to see this
it's the propaganda it's big music
they're telling you you have to like
it's your point by the way do we even
care why they broke up at this point no
we do they broke up they broke up no one
really cared mom and dad why did you
guys get divorced
when was the last time you listened to a
song by the beatles on spotify do not
lie i did it on vinyl on sunday yeah
hey on vinyl yesterday i am choking on
the pretension right now no one actually
has finals is it pretention or do i
actually know what i'm talking about
[Laughter]
[Music]
so ringo did it wait
cat isn't that the bigger story is that
no matter how well you get along in a
band no matter what you end up hating
each other is that kind of how it
happens yes
yes too much time together only there
was a tv show that i could reference
yeah but i won't though
we'll never break up
yeah yeah answer my questions i am the
only person who thinks overrated
i'm a stone's guy a led zeppelin guy i'm
not a big beetle guy there's songs you
could be all tyrus yeah it's just the
the hairdos the bowl cut the beatles did
did some really interesting things
there's and they they created basically
they basically created they
they changed music forever but that's
not enough for buck sexton
what do you listen to in your shag wagon
kesha you're shagging wagon whoa
i told you
as a friend you're not supposed
[Applause]
and backed it up on him the b sides of
lady gaga are something that all
red-blooded americans but i think we can
all end this segment on one thing ringo
did yes
[Music]
we must move on hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else